[Music]
with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may act eight each
other and you thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge it's been yet
another tumultuous week of brexit with
fears of an Odile reaching fever pitch
and now one of the UK's largest super
markets has started stocking a rare
delicacy just for us Brits forget
baguettes and Brie oh yes it's barbecue
favored crickets they are now on across
the country no.not wants to be outdone
by a certain reality TV show not
mentioning any names we have our own
supplies so come on guys who's up for a
bit of pledged taco challenge now go
dumb if it's good enough for the celebs
in the jungle is good enough for the
panelists on the pledge coming up Nick
calls for more respect for our police
officers Phill ones time not talking
Maja's says nota ban yeas are me and
Rachel's stuck in a man's world but
first it's me and we finished with
crickets
they say week is a long time in politics
for Theresa May last week it was
probably the longest of her 30 years in
Westminster no sooner had she announced
the terms of her ill-fated brexit deal
the Tory knives were out hoping to chop
away at her already severed leadership
now I'm no fan of mrs. may politically I
think she seriously failed to live up to
many of the promises she made during her
first speech as PM
she hasn't championed the women in her
cabinet however it now seems that she
too is a victim of misogyny breaks a is
a shambles but so many of the men who
are to blame for it have jumped ship
Cameron Davis Johnson robbed or gone
leaving may as the lone woman willing to
try and steer us to Karma sees albeit
haphazardly
similarly in America Nancy Pelosi just
delivered the Democrats their biggest
victory in the House of Representatives
that since Watergate but instead of
thanking her the recipients of this win
are staging a coup to oust her sadly it
seems in politics a woman's work is not
only never done it's never fair I've
still got these crickets it was a batty
idea to do it cometh the hour cometh as
a woman yeah I think I possibly agree
with you just so the vo to a to a point
that's just so the viewers are
absolutely up to speed here's a look at
who's resigned from the cabinet in
recent months we go back to the 8th of
July brexit secretary David Davis a
fella stepped down saying he couldn't
support the checkers proposal just a day
later some fella by the name of Boris
Johnson Foreign Secretary also left his
post over the plans to the 15th of
November last week both BRICS its
secretary Dominick rabe and Work and
Pensions Secretary s term availeth the
government over two resumes brixon neil
they've also been numerous parent
ministers and others who stepped down
from their roles including Joe Johnson
there's another one so well at
brotherman ghetto babe Steve Baker and
Andrea Jenkins where I think you're
absolutely right and I think she's
probably had enough of this and I was
privileged enough to sweep of the last
week the focus on how she's coping how
are you if it wasn't blow no suggestion
that you're working 23 and a half hour
days jumping on planes and trains to
Brussels that's what you do because it's
how's your now I know she has diabetes
so I get old but they focus a lot on
their to support your line as well I
thought the way and I've said this
before and I probably lose my colleagues
of my right here but I thought the way
that mostly European male leaders ganged
up on her a few months ago in Salzburg
was thank you so Janine to quote one of
your words back to you so I
with you there sadly it seems to be in
the conservative DNA that they have to
do leaders in I think it's probably that
they all feel they should be leaders
themselves they all think they can do a
better job but where they're wrong I
will and I will yield after this where I
think they're wrong if as I've been
fortunate to do I've been traveling a
bit this last week if you get out away
from the Westminster press corps if you
get out over the heads actually of some
of our own MPs if you actually talk to
normal decent people who are watching
this show watching this show you'll pay
their taxes everything else they just
want the deal yeah you've just been
charmed because you've met her clearly
right and that's why you've always been
objective I have to I am I feel though
some of the points are relevant like you
know perhaps asking about her health and
what on man's but that all that means
really they should be asking about men's
health as well I just feel like we're
trying to shoehorn something into a
topic that may not fit necessarily
because we are after all talking about
the only party that has elected to
female prime ministers and the Labour
Party hasn't done that yet and I hate
you for this because you're making me
defend the Tories what am i doing but
actually I just I just feel sometimes
what we're in danger of undermining a
very important topic which is
challenging misogyny if we try and fit
it too hard into something that doesn't
necessarily fit so look at the women who
are also Brett it is penny more Don you
know we've got we've got Andrew Ned
someone got estimate Fay there are women
involved in backstabbing her as well not
so that with the exception of mr.
methane not to the same extent they were
clearly cheerleaders in the sense we can
discuss tone but you know I think
balancing it up against the fact that we
were yet still yet to have a female
leader of the Labour Party which I a
gondolier Denton saying misogyny doesn't
exist in a Labour Party I think the
sahjhan he exists in politics in general
yeah what I'm saying is the way she is
being treated I do not believe a man
would be treated the same way and can we
have it was a lonely place for her
a--casey sees on the pinnacle she's
doing a bits and pieces she was going to
get a rough ride from the start I mean
after all she is she wanted to remain
and she's trying to do a job that she
probably hasn't got the whole heart
behind this
FairPoint of forgiving she still do
something she'd soon or not Andrea let's
stop she was sort of hope here in the
very disappeared out the door no way and
can we have a look I've want to show you
well first let me bring up a quote from
our Conservative MP Nick Bowles who
agrees with me do my colleagues not
understand how normal people react when
they see a group of middle-aged men led
by two plummy tony old Etonians trying
to bully a conscientious and determined
woman out of her job I agree with him
and now can I look at speaking of her
plummy toned eat old Etonians so we have
a look at this image which is the modern
brand global Britain I think not they
were the future one that's what I agree
Rachel is by the way because that and
they're appealing to young people who
are protected in the roaming it's just
absurd that was the best advertisement
for staying in the EU everything June I
do I sort of on your page for a tiny bit
glitch as I think that's as in that Nick
Bowles tweet I think a lot of men think
she that's my job yeah you know they
feel that entitled to be there running
the country and they see a woman running
the country and they sort of feel
slightly cheated but I just don't think
the issue here is misogyny I think the
problem with resume it's like brexit the
problem with rex it is brexit okay
problem is not Teresa may people's
feelings about Teresa may Teresa me it
Mae's health Teresa Mays handling of the
negotiations although maybe we could
argue that the problem is she cannot
deliver either to those who don't want
to leave Europe one to those who do want
to leave Europe and what people see and
the reason she's coming in for a huge
amount of on you know she's she's on the
ropes it's because remainders see that
she's a remainer who's taking the
country over a cliff not in the national
interest and those who leave
she's leaving the country right here yes
I think she's can you see that there's
25 people who have already come out
against her five of which are women all
of whom are women but you know she needs
only seven Tory rebels to vote against
her and she loses because actually she
has recovered somewhat from last week
last week 33 percent of voters back to
his amazed days p.m. and 47% wanted her
to go but this week it's almost been
reversed 46 percent of voters back to
his and they staying as p.m. this week
and thought 34 percent now want her to
go though actually of course the real
poll that matters is in Parliament the
moment is yes I used to bring in Kenneth
Clark and he's very interesting because
he's supporting treasom a he will vote
for the deal and he is obviously one of
the earth remaineth in Parliament one
which is critical which basically is a
signal to everybody that this deal of
mate means this is a no brexit deal
let's hear what kind of plan says I
found in the last three or four days ago
wave of public sympathy towards her but
they do see a woman who's been very
badly treated by people she's been
trying to reach compromises with and boy
is she tough so you have Ken Clark
coming out in support of syriza made
because he likes her deal he's not
calling her a bloody different woman
though no okay I totally agree with you
to a certain point Rachel but don't you
think it's quite interesting that she's
the one who has stuck it out who is not
bailing out who is taking all the
punches and all the men have jumped ship
and are then from the back benches
sitting there criticising yes look at
what why do they say the monster mug
yes mr. mug
indeed it's a rather silly word because
what I have done and what others have
done is used the democratic process
within the Conservative Party to say we
have no confidence in the leader of the
Conservative Party this is not an
illegitimate process it's one set out of
the rules and this type of language is
over eggplant which is rather damaging
to political debate because it tries to
see things in terms that are not
realistic they're not true well
something like that
I'm glad that backfired on him but where
I do agree again is that she's got a
terribly difficult job in BRICS it is a
poisoned chalice and no matter what she
does no matter how good she is all sides
are going to be at this stage upset with
her for one reason or another but do we
agree that things that the obstacles are
the odds are stacked even more against
her because she's a woman